the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so again welcome back and today's topic
is a continuation of what we did last
time we still have a little bit of work
in thinking to do concerning polar
coordinates so we're going to talk about
polar coordinates and my first job today
is to talk a little bit about area
that's something we've we we didn't
mention last time and since we're all
back from Thanksgiving we can certainly
talk about it in terms of a pie which is
the basic idea for area and polar
coordinates here's our pie and here's a
slice of the pie the slice has a piece
of arc length on it which I'm going to
call Delta Theta and the area of that
shaded in slice I'm going to call Delta
a and let's suppose that the radius is a
little a so this is a pie of radius a
that's our picture now it's pretty easy
to figure out what the area of that
slice of pie is the total area is of
course PI a squared we know that and to
get this fraction Delta a all we have to
do is take the percentage of the arc of
the total circumference that's Delta
Theta divided by 2 pi this is the
fraction of area sorry fraction of the
total circumference the total length
around the rim and then we multiply that
by PI a squared and that's giving us the
total area and if you work that out
that's Delta a is equal to the PI's
cancel and we have 1/2
a squared Delta Theta alright so here's
the the basic formula and now what we
need to do is to talk about a variable
pi that would be a PI with a kind of a
wavy crust right which is coming around
like this so R is equal to R of theta
the the distance from the center is
varying with the with the place where we
are the angle where we're shooting out
and now I want to subdivide that into
little chunks here now the idea for
adding up the area the total area of
this this piece that's swept out is to
break it up into little slices whose
whose areas are almost easy to calculate
namely what we're going to do is to take
and I'm going to I'm going to label it
this way I'm going to take these little
circular arcs which go so I'm going to
extend past where the where this goes
and then I'm going to take each circular
arc here so here's a circular arc and
then here's another circular arc and
here's another circular arc it's just
right on the nose in that case now in
these two cases so so basically the
picture that I'm trying to draw for you
is is this I have some some sector and
then I have some circular arc and it may
be it it takes a little extra there's a
little extra area I'm making an error in
the area this is a little extra area and
maybe to draw it the other way there's a
little I'm a little short on this one
and let's say on this one I'm right on
the nose I have the same arc as the
curve of the of the surface alright now
this is a little bit like the step
functions that we used in Riemann
somes it's practically the same
eventually this little band of stuff
that we're missing by if we take very
very narrow little slices here is going
to be negligible it'll get closer and
closer to the curve itself so that area
will tend to 0 in the limit so we don't
have to worry about it and the
approximate relationship is sitting here
where this distance now is R so this
radius is R and this is this Delta Theta
and so in the approximate case what we
have is the Delta a is approximately 1/2
R squared Delta Theta which is
practically the same thing we had here
except that that R is replacing the
constant there and it's approximately
true because R is varying and then in
the limit we have the exact formula for
the differential which is this one so
this is the main formula for area and if
you like the total area then is going to
be the integral from some starting place
to some end place of 1/2 R squared D
theta now this is only useful in this
situation that we're in namely so this
is the other important formula and this
is only when R is a function of theta
and this is the way in which the region
is presented to us all right so that's
the that's a set up and that's our
formula main formula let's do an example
the example that I'm going to take is
the one that we did at the end of last
time or near the end of last time which
was this formula here R is equal to 2a
cosine theta remember that was the same
as X minus a squared plus y squared
equals a squared so this is what we did
last time we connected this rectangular
representation to that polar
representation and the the picture is of
a circle
right where this is the point to a comma
zero all right so let's figure out what
the area is well first of all we have to
figure out when we sweep out the area we
have to realize that we only go for
minus PI over 2 to PI over 2 so that's
something we can get from the picture
you can also get it directly from this
formula if you realize that cosine is
positive in this range here and at the
ends it's zero so the thing encloses a
region at these ends so at the ends
cosine of cosine of plus or minus PI
over two is equal to zero that's what
what cinches this up like a little sack
if you like all right so the area is now
going to be the integral from minus PI
over 2 to PI over 2 of 1/2 times the
square of R that's to a cosine theta
squared D thing question
how do I know from looking at the
picture that I'm going from negative PI
over 2 to PI over 2 is the question I I
do it very like with my whole body I say
Here I am pointing down that's negative
PI over 2 I sweep up that's zero and I
get all the way up to here that's PI
over 2 so that's the way I do it that's
really the way I do it I'm being honest
now if you if you're a machine you can't
actually look and you don't have a body
so you can't point your arms then you
would have to go by the formulas and
you'd have to actually use something
like this formula here the fact that
that this is where the loop cinches up
this is where the radius comes in to 0
at PI over 2 so you need to know that in
order to understand the range all right
another question
so when we're doing age and we just
guess that it's going to be a loo I'm
probably going to give you some clues as
to what's going on because it's very
hard to figure these things out
sometimes it'll be bounded by one curve
and another curve and I'll say it's the
thing in between those two curves that's
the kind of thing that I could do here
you really should have know this one in
advance this is by far the most where
this is one of the typical cases anyway
I'm going to give you a couple more
examples don't don't get too worked up
over this you will somehow be able to
visualize it I'll give you some examples
to help you out with it later all right
so here's the situation here's my
integral and now we're faced with a trig
integral which we have to remember how
to do now the trig integral here so
first let me factor out the constants
this is 4a squared divided by 2 so it's
2 a squared integral from minus PI over
2 PI over 2 cosine squared theta D theta
and now you have to remember what you're
supposed to do at this point
so think if you haven't done it yet this
is practice you need to do this trig
integral is handled by a double angle
formula is it happens I'm going to be
giving you these formulas on the review
sheet you'll see they're written on the
review sheet at least in some form so
for example there's a there's a formula
right and this will be on the exam too
so this is the correct formula to use
here is that this is 1 plus cosine 2
theta divided by 2 D theta so that's the
substitution that you use for the cosine
squared in order to integrate it that
serves as a little review of trig
integrals and now this is this is quite
easy alright this is this integral now
is easy
why is it easy well because it's the
antiderivative of a constant and cosine
2 theta its antiderivative you're
supposed to be able to write down so the
antiderivative of 1 is theta and the
antiderivative of the cosine is 1/2 the
sine when it's 2 theta alright and that
is a squared times pi over 2 minus minus
PI over 2 and the signs go away because
they're both 0 so all told we get PI a
squared which is certainly what we would
like it to be it's the area of the
circle another question
the question so I'm not sure which
question you're asking I pivoted my arm
around zero zero this point this is the
point we're talking about zero zero is a
key point it's where I guess you could
say I stuck my elbow there okay now the
reason is that it's the place where R
equals zero so it's more or less the
center of the universe from the point of
view of this this problem so it's the
reference point and and if you like when
you're doing this it's a little bit like
a radar screen everything is centered at
the origin and you're taking rays coming
out from it and seeing where they're
going to go all right
so for example this is the theta equals
zero ray this is the theta equals PI
over four ray this is the theta equals
PI over two ray and indeed if my elbow
is right at this center here I'm
pointing in those various directions all
right so that's what I had in mind when
I did that
okay you can always get these formulas
by the way from the original business X
equals R cosine theta y equals R sine
theta but it's useful to have the
geometric picture as well in other words
if you were a machine you'd have to rely
on these formulas and plot things using
these always okay
now in terms of plotting I want to I
want to expand your brain a little bit
so we need just a little bit more
practice with plotting in polar
coordinates and so the first question
that I want to ask you is what happens
outside of this range of theta in other
words what happens if theta is beyond PI
over two can somebody can somebody see
what's happening to the formulas in that
case so so what I'm looking at now let's
go back to it what I'm looking at is
this formula here all right but to use
the elbow analogy here I'm sweep swept
around like this but now I'm going to
point this way I'm going to point out
that over there my hand is up here in
the northwest direction alright so
what's going to happen somebody want to
tell me
it goes it goes around itself that's
right what happens is that when our
crosses this vertical are a zero when it
crosses over here it goes negative so
although my theta is pointing me this
way
the thing is going to go backwards and
there's another clue which is very
important how far backwards is it going
well you don't actually need to know
anything but this equation here to
understand that it has to be on the same
circle so when I'm pointing this way the
thing points backwards to this point
over there so what happens is it goes
around once and then when I point out
this way it sweeps around a second time
it just keeps on going around the same
circle so over here it's empty because
it's pointing the other way and it's
sweeping around the same curve the
second time right now if you were
foolish enough to integrate say from
zero to 2pi or some wider range what
would happen is you would just double
the area because you would have swept it
out twice all right so that's the
mistake that you'll make sometimes
you'll count things as negative and
positive but because there's an arson
there's a square here it's always a
positive quantity and you'll always over
count if you if you go too far all right
so that's that's that's what happens
again it sweeps out the same region
that's because these two equations
really are equivalent to each other it's
just that this one sweeps it out twice
and this one doesn't say how its
sweeping it out yeah another question
does this equation also work if you just
go from 0 to PI
does the integration work and you just
go from zero to pi the answer is yes
that's a very weird object though let me
just show you what that is if you
started from zero to 2pi so I'll
illustrate it on here the first thing
you've swept out between zero and PI
over two is this part here that was
swept out and then when you're going
around this this next quadrant here
you're actually sweeping out this
underside here so actually you're
getting it because you're getting the
half of it on one half and getting the
other half on the other quadrant so it's
actually giving you the right answer
okay so that's that turns out to be okay
it's a little weird way to chop up a
circle but it's but it's legal okay but
of course that's an accident of this
particular figure you can't count on
that happening it's much better to line
it up exactly with what the figure does
all right so don't don't don't do that
too often you might run into troubles
all right
so I'm going to give you a couple more
examples of practice with them with
these pictures and maybe let's see I'm
going to get rid of this one up here so
here's another favorite
here's another favorite so this if you
like as example two I guess we had an
example one up there and now we're
really not going to try to do any more
area examples the area examples are
actually straightforward it's really
just figuring out what the picture looks
like so so these are this is examples of
drawings so this one is is one that's
kind of fun to to do this is ours sine 2
theta something like this is on your
homework and so what happens here is the
following
what happens here is that at R equals so
at theta equals zero that's the first
place this is so let's let's just plot a
few places here
I'm not going to plot very many theta is
equal to zero I get R is 1
whoops I get R 0 sorry and then PI over
4 that's where I get sine PI over 2 I
get 1 here for this and then again at PI
over 2 I get sine PI which is back at 0
again so it's it's and the other thing
to say is in between here it's positive
in between so what it does is it starts
out at 0 and it goes out to the radius 1
over here
and then it comes back alright so it
does something like this it goes out and
it comes back now because of the
symmetries of the sine function this is
pretty much all you need to know it does
something similar in all of the
quadrants but in order to see what it's
doing
there's it's useful for you to watch me
draw it because the order is very
important for understanding what it's
doing it's similar to this business
weird business with a circle here so
watch me draw this this guy I'll draw it
in red because it usually has a name so
here it is it does this thing and then
it does this and then it does this and
then it does that all right so it's
called a corley Rose I drew it in pink
because it's kind of a rose here right
so it started out over here this is step
one and this is the range 0 less than
theta is less than PI over 4 all right
it did this part here and then it went
to here so I should draw these in white
because they're harder to read and in
red and but now look at what it did it
did not make a right angle turn it was
nice and smooth it went around here and
then it went down he
this is three back here that's four and
then over here that's five back up here
that's six and then around here that's
seven and down here that's eight and
then back where it started and goes
around again all right and this is
because actually it's switching sign
when it crosses the origin when it was
over in this quadrant the first time it
actually was tracing what's directly
behind it all right so this is kind of
amusing from this little tiny formula
you get this pretty diagram here anyway
that's as I say an old favorite and here
you know if you want to do the area of
one leaf you've got to make sure you
understand that it's a small piece of
the whole okay now I have one last
drawing example that I want to discuss
with you and it involves another skill
that we haven't quite gotten enough
practice with so I'm going to do that
one and it's also preparation for an
exercise but one that we're going to do
after the test so so here's my last
example we're going to discuss what
happens with this function here sorry
that's not legible is it that's a cosine
R is equal to one over one plus two
cosine theta now the first thing I want
to do is just take our time a little bit
and plot a few points so here's the
values of theta and here the values of R
and we'll see what happens
we'll try to figure out what it's doing
when theta is equal to zero cosine is 1
so R is 1/3 all right that's the
denominator is 1 plus 2 so it's 1/3
if theta I'm going to make it easy we're
not going to do so many I'm going to do
PI over 2 that's an easy value of the
cosine that's cosine of PI over 2 0 so
that value of R is 1 and now I'm going
to back up and do minus PI over 2 minus
PI over 2 again cosine is 0 and R is 1
so now I'd like to just plot those
points anyway and see what's going on
with this with this expression here the
first one is it a rectangular I'm going
to write the rectangular coordinates
here not the polar coordinates the
rectangular coordinates here is it's 1/3
out at the horizontal so it's a 1/3 0
all right the polar coordinate is 0 1/3
is is 1/3 0 but the where Tangela
coordinate is also that and over here at
PI over 2 the distance is 1 so this is
the point 0 comma 1 in XY coordinates
and then down here at negative PI over 2
it's 0 comma minus 1 let me just
emphasize if you you should be able to
think of this visually if you can crank
your arm around and and and think it or
if you're if you're right-handed you'll
have to bend that right now anyway or
you'll have to use but but this also
works using this formulas x equals R
cosine theta y equals R sine theta
notice that in this case R was 1 but the
cosine was 0 so you plug in theta equals
minus PI over 2 and R equals 1 and lo
and behold you get 0 here and here you
get minus 1 and here you get 1 so this
is minus 1 alright so this is an example
I did it purely visually or sort of
organically but you can also do it by
plugging in the numbers all right now in
between
the denominator is positive and it's
something in between it's going to it's
going to sweep around something like
this alright that's what happens in
between as theta increases from minus PI
over 2 to PI over 2 and now something
interesting happens with this particular
function which is that we notice that
the denominator is 0 at a certain place
namely if I solve 2 cosine theta is
equal to negative 1 then the denominator
is going to be 0 there that's cosine
theta is equal to a minus 1/2 so theta
is equal to it turns out plus or minus 2
PI over 3
those are the values here so when we're
out here somewhere in these directions
there's nothing it's going infinitely
far out those ways all right ok that's
all about as much as we'll be able to
figure out of this diagram without doing
some analytic work and that's the other
little piece that I want to explain
namely going backwards from polar
coordinates to rectangular coordinates
which is one thing that we haven't done
so let's let's do that so what is the
rectangular equation that means the XY
equation for this R equals 1 over 1 plus
2 cosine theta and let's see what it is
well first I'm going to clear the
denominator here this is R plus 2 R
cosine theta equals 1 and now I'm going
to rewrite it as R equals 1 minus 2 R
cosine theta and the reason for that is
that in a minute
I'll explain to you why this is 1 minus
2x and this guy I'm going to square
now I'm going to make this R squared
equals 1 minus 2x squared and now with
an R squared I can plug in x squared
plus y squared alright so this is a
standard thing to do and it's basically
what you're going to do anytime you're
faced with an equation like this is try
to work it out and in these situations
it will where you have 1 over a plus B
cosine theta or sine theta you'll always
come out with some quadratic expression
like this now I'm going to combine terms
so here I have minus 3x squared plus y
squared and put everything on the right
of the left side so that's this alright
and we recognize well you're supposed to
recognize that this is what's known as a
hyperbola if the signs are the same it's
an ellipse if the signs are opposite
it's a hyperbola and in between if one
of the coefficients on the quadratic is
0 it's a parabola so now we see that
what we the picture that we drew there
is actually turns out it's going to have
asymptotes it's going to be a hyperbola
all right so now let me ask you the last
little mind-bending question that I want
to ask which is what happens so now I'm
using my right arm I guess but my elbows
at the origin here what happens if I
pass outside to the range where this
denominator is negative it crossed zero
and it went to negative and sweeping out
something over here is it is it sweeping
out the same curve anybody have any idea
what it's doing yeah
yeah exactly good answer
it's the other branch of the hyperbola
okay so what's actually happening is in
disguise there's another branch of the
hyperbola which is being swept out by
the other piece of this thing now that
is consistent with these algebraic
equations the algebraic equation that I
got here doesn't say which branch of the
hyperbola I've got it's actually got two
branches and the curve really was in
disguise capturing both of them I want
to make the connection now with the the
the basic formula for area here because
this is this is a really beautiful
connection and I want to make that
connection in connection also with this
with this example the hyperbolas as you
probably know are the trajectories of
comets and ellipses which is what you
would get if you maybe you put a half
here instead of a two would be the
trajectories of planets or asteroids but
there's actually something much more
important physically that goes on that's
special about this particular
representation of the hyperbola and what
happens when you get the ellipses as
well which is that in this case R equals
zero is the focus of the hyperbola and
what that means is that it's actually
the place where the Sun is so this is
the right representation if you want the
center of gravity in the center of your
picture
and pretty much any other I mean you
can't tell that at all from the
algebraic equations here so this
hyperbola is going to be the trajectory
of some comet going by here and this
formula here is actually a rather
central formula in astronomy namely
there's something called Kepler's law
which says that the rate of change of
area which is swept out is constant the
rate of change of area relative to the
center of mass relative to the Sun so in
equal areas this is the the amount of
area so this tells you now that when a
comet goes around the Sun like this its
speed varies and it speed varies
according to a very specific rule namely
this one here and this rule was observed
by Kepler but if you have this
connection here we also have something
else we also know that da DT is equal to
1/2 R squared D theta DT alright so
that's that's this formula here formally
dividing by T that's the rate of change
with respect to this time parameter
which is the honest-to-goodness time
real physical time and that means this
quantity here is constant
and this is one of the key insights that
physicists had long after Kepler made
his physical observations they realized
that he was had managed to get the best
physics experiment at all because it's a
frictionless setup right outer space
there's no air nothing is going on this
is what's known nowadays as conservation
of angular momentum this is this is the
expression for angular momentum and what
and what Kepler was observing it turns
out is what we see all the time in real
life which is when you start something
spinning around it continues to spin it
roughly the same rate or if you're an
ice skater and you get yourself
scrunched together a little bit more you
can spin faster and there's an exact
quantitative rule that does that and
it's exactly this polar formula here all
right so that's that's a neat thing and
we will do a little exercise on this
rate of change after the exam okay so
that's it for generalities and a little
pep talk on what's coming up to you when
you learn a little more physics right
now we need to talk about the exam okay
so first of all
let me tell you what the topics are
they're the same as last year's test
which you can take a look at and well
let's see so what do we do
one of the main topics of this unit
we're techniques of integration and
there are three which are which we will
test one is trig substitution one is
integration by parts and one is partial
fractions so that's more than half of
the exam right there the other half of
the exam is parametric curves arc length
these are all interrelated and us area
of surfaces of revolution those are the
only kind that we can handle just as we
did with volume of surfaces of
revolution and then there's a final
topic which is polar coordinates and
area in polar quarters including area
all right that's it that's what's on the
test there are six problems they're very
similar well they're not actually that
similar but they're somewhat similar the
last year's I'd say that test is a tiny
bit well similar similar maybe it's I
nee bit more difficult well we'll see
we'll see
yeah the question was we didn't do arc
length in polar coordinates did we and
the answer is no we did not we did not
do arc length in polar coordinates when
I give you an exercise I'm going to ask
you about if you know the speed of a
comet here what's the speed of the comet
there and we'll have to know about arc
length for that but we're not doing it
on this exam other questions the
question is will you will I expect you
to know our equals so let's see if I can
formulate this question it's related to
this four-leaf rose here so the question
is suppose I gave you something that
looked like this would I expect you to
be able to know what it is I think the
answer the fair answer to give you is if
it's this complicated it would there all
I only have two possibilities I can give
you a long time to sketch this out and
think about what it does or I can tell
you that it happens to be a three leaf
rose and then you and then you have some
clue as to what it's doing okay it
doesn't have six because of some weird
thing having to do with repetitions but
the odds and the evens work differently
so so that's so in fact you so so I
would have to tell you what the picture
looks like if it's going to be this
complicated all right similarly so this
is an important
going to make when we come to techniques
of integration in any integral that you
have I'm not going to tell you which of
these three techniques to use on the
ones which are straightforward integrals
but if it's an integral that I think
you're going to get stuck on either I'm
going to give you a hint you know to
tell you how to do it or I'm going to
tell you don't do it if I tell you don't
do it don't try to do it it may be
impossible and even if it's possible
it's going to be very long like you know
an hour so don't don't do it unless I
tell you to on the other hand all of
these setups in the second half of this
unit they involved somehow setting
something up and the there they're
basically three issues one is what the
integrand is one is one is what the
lower limit is and one what is the upper
limit right they're just they're just
three things three inputs to setting up
an integral all integrals this is this
is going to be the set up for all of
them and then the second step is
evaluating which really is what we did
in the first half here and unfortunately
we don't have infinitely many techniques
and indeed there's some integrals that
can't be evaluated and some that are too
long so we'll just try to avoid those
I'm not trying to give you ones which
are hopelessly long all right other
questions yes
the last exam about 30 points two or
three
the question is will the percentages be
the same and the answer is no this I can
I'll tell you exactly this is fifty five
points unless I change the point values
this is fifty five and this is 45 all
right
that's that's what it came out to be all
right you are going to want to know
about all of the things that I've
written down here you're definitely
going to want to know for example
surfaces of revolution how did how to
set those up yes there was another
question I saw yes
so you have a partial fraction with
something like X plus 2 the quantity
squared in it and maybe an X and maybe
an X plus 1 and it is this what we're is
this the type of so and you're
interested in what happens with this
denominator here so what what's going to
happen is you're going to need a
coefficient for each degree of this so
altogether the set up is going to be
this plus 1 for X and 1 for X plus 1
this is this is the the the set up all
right so you need yeah
right so if I change this to being a
three here then I need well I guess I'll
have to write it call it e X plus two
cubed I need that now it gets harder and
harder the more repeated roots there are
the more repeated factors there are the
harder it is because the ones you can
pick off by the cover-up method are is
that just the top one here and these two
so C D and E you can get but B and a
you're going to have to do by either
plugging in or some other more elaborate
algebra so the more of these lower terms
there are the worse off you are
she
the question is does this sq+ 21 affect
the setup and the answer is almost no
that is not at all
it's the same setup exactly but there's
one thing if the degree gets too big
then you've got to use a long division
first to knock it down all right okay I
have I'll give you an example of this
type I've practiced unless there are
more questions yes
are you having to know how to do
reduction formulas anything that's a
little out of the ordinary like a
reduction formula I will have to coach
you to do so in other words what you'll
have to be able to do in that situation
is follow directions if I tell you okay
you're faced with this then do an
integration by parts and do that then
you'll get the reduction formula okay
yeah okay so the question had to do with
the partial fractions method and what
happens if you have a what happens if
you have a quadratic so for instance if
it were this this one's too disgusting
I'm going to just do it with two of them
all right so the the parts with X and X
plus 1 are the same but now you have
linear factors here ax plus B divided by
x squared plus 2 and a maybe I'll call
them 1 and a 2 X plus B 2 x squared plus
2 squared plus C over X plus D over X
plus 1 all right this is this is the way
it works okay I'm going to give you one
more quick example of an integration
technique just to to liven things up
let's see so here's a somewhat tricky
example this is just a little trickier
than I would give you on a test but it's
the same principle and I may do this on
a on a final exam so suppose you're
suppose you have this you're faced with
this integral what are you going to do
integration by parts great that's right
that's because this guy is begging to be
differentiated to be made simpler
alright so that means that I want this
one to be you and I want this one to be
V Prime and I want to use integration by
parts and then u prime is equal to 1
over 1 plus x squared and V is equal to
x squared over 2 all right so the answer
is now x squared over 2 tan inverse X
minus the integral of this guy which is
going to be x squared over 2 and then I
have 1 over 1 plus x squared DX
alright now you are not done at this
point all right you're still in slightly
hot water
all right it's your tepid water anyway
so what is it that you have to do here
you're faced with this integral which
I'll put on the next board it's a lot
simpler than the other one but it's I
say you're not quite out of the woods
you're faced with the integral of 1/2
minus 1/2 x squared over 1 plus x
squared DX
trig substitution actually amazing
interestingly will work but that wasn't
what I wanted you to do I wanted you to
yeah go ahead and try to go into the
numerator so now that that's the correct
answer now this is the case where the
numerator and the denominator are tied
and so you have to use a long division
but a shortcut is just to observe that
the look the result of long division is
the same thing as doing this ok and then
notice saying that this is 1 minus 1
over 1 plus X all right so this is the
same as long division in this case
because when you divide in it goes in
with a quotient of 1 alright and so this
guy turns out to be minus 1/2 the
integral of 1 minus 1 over 1 plus x
squared DX which is 1/2 X minus tan
inverse all right so so so this is this
is one extra step that you you may be
faced with at some some day in your life
and just keep that in mind